la normalización de las relaciones entre
colombia y venezuela se ve más cerca en
uno de sus primeros gestos como
presidente electo gustavo petro hizo el
anuncio vía twitter
me he comunicado con el gobierno
venezolano para abrir la frontera y
reestablecer el pleno ejercicio de los
derechos humanos en la frontera
colombia y venezuela comparten 2.219
kilómetros de frontera en 2008 el
intercambio comercial era de 7200
millones de dólares cifra que se fue
reduciendo hasta 2020 cuando cayó a los
221 millones de dólares en su lugar la
frontera se volvió porosa y controlada
por grupos armados que la han estado
aprovechando para actividades ilícitas
la elección de gustavo petro era vista
con esperanza por los habitantes de la
frontera
pero tenemos sobre todo
hasta que también ha sido una petición
recurrente del presidente de venezuela
nicolás maduro así hablaba en octubre de
2021 para empezar a conversar y avanzar
en la regularización de las relaciones
consulares
diplomática económica
comerciales y en general en las
relaciones
institucionales políticas y humanas
entre colombia y venezuela
venezuela cerró la frontera en 2015 tras
un enfrentamiento entre el ejército
venezolano y civiles maduro culpó al
paramilitarismo y al expresidente álvaro
uribe desde entonces el paso ha estado
cerrado vehículos más tarde en 2019
rompieron relaciones cuando iván duque
reconoció al opositor juan guaidó como
presidente interino una relaciones que
podrían recuperarse con la llegada del
primer gobierno de izquierda de colombia
[Aplausos]